[Applause]
oh I'm telling you nobody here can I can
I tell you my favorite part cuz I was
reading her a pre-interview and like all
the things like I've seen you in Book of
Mormon I've seen been frozen or heard
you in froze all the things that you
don't tell him what you know when you
mentioned new girl that's our pool thank
you you're too young you are so
unbelievably talented
thank you listening to your song in the
car this morning I don't know my name
and I I'm blown away by your mesmerizing
really shocked you shouldn't lose that
though I think it's cool when you get so
excited about meeting people I'm 37
years old I still ask Meryl Streep I
look like an idiot but I have whatever I
don't care
Miley said mine was Harrison Ford
imagine how that went oh my god would be
quiet I literally was like I love you
and he's like all right so why bear claw
why was that your boy I love new girls I
actually just did an interview with
Zooey Deschanel oh I love is like a
die-hard New Girl fans but they told me
on the phone they were like okay it's so
like someone's gonna be sitting with you
on the couch and I'm like oh okay and so
they were like oh I was like who is it
and they were like Josh GAD I was like
who's that so I didn't know who that was
so I'm like a huge fan but I know you as
bear claw so there are so many emotions
that I'm going through right
nito who you were then when I learned me
where I cried I know what you mean
though cuz I don't ever know everybody's
real name especially an actor John the
same way yeah and I always think that
they're the person they were in the
movie and they're not I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this